in the wake of the Hamas terror attack
on Israel and the subsequent Israeli
response on Gaza most people around the
world are looking for a way to stop the
escalation and restore peace before we
all end up in full-blown World War most
people but not Lindsey Graham who
suggests instead that we bomb Iran for
every Israeli or American hostage
executed uh by Hamas we should uh take
down an AR Ian oil refinery the only way
you're going to keep this war from
escalating is to hold Iran accountable
how much more death and destruction do
we have to take from the Iranian regime
I am confident this was planned and
funded by the Iranians Hamas is a bunch
of animals uh who deserve to be treated
like animals so if I was Israel I would
go in on the ground there is no truth to
be had here I would dismantle Hamas this
is the best opportunity Israel has to
destroy Hamas take it to the Iranians if
you harm one American in Syria by using
your Iranian militia against us in Syria
if you escalate the war by urging
Hezbollah to attack Israel in the north
if Hamas kills one American Israeli
hostage we're going to blow up your oil
refineries and put you out of business
it is now time to take the war to the
ayatollah's
backyard no no it's not that's a bad
idea that is in fact the exact opposite
of a good
idea I like Lindsey Graham I know a lot
of people don't like him I like him I
get a kick out of him he's a nice guy no
and in Lindsey Graham's defense bomb
Iran is in fact Lindsey Graham's answer
to almost every question what would you
like for lunch today sir bomb Iran
sparkling or still bomb Iran please
enter your four-digit pin
bomb
Iran enter
that's one foreign policy preference but
it is not the right one the Hamas attack
was hideous Israeli retaliation is
Justified and the American interest is
clear contain the war before events
spiral out of our control I'm Michael
nolles this the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
this episode's brought to you by good
ranchers get great meet at a secure
price and 30 bucks off your order with
my code nolles KW Lees good ranchers.com
use code nolles today uh we have Senator
Rand Paul coming up on the show a little
bit later we're going to get to senator
Paul even before the member block uh
today so stay tuned for that but before
that while we talk about Senator Paul's
Senate colleague Lindsey Graham calling
to bomb Iran there are a lot of voices
calling to bomb Iran and escalate the
war even if they are arguing that such
an action would deescalate the War I
just want to give you a little picture
of the threat assessment capabilities of
the US government right now uh Joe Biden
and his spokesman his sort of spokesman
John Kirby are arguing that the biggest
threat to the American people the
biggest danger that we face is not Hamas
it's not Iran it's not war of any kind
it's not even a nuclear bomb it's the
sun monster the only existential threat
Humanity faces even more frightening
than a than a nuclear war is global
warming going above 1.5 degrees in the
next 20 10 years given all the nuclear
players in these two areas where we are
now engaged on does the president stand
by that comment absolutely he does
climate change is an existential threat
it could you know it actually threatens
and is capable of wiping out all human
life on Earth uh over time I mean that's
I don't know how more existential you
can get to that but that doesn't mean
that we walk away from our obligations
our national security interest in very
dangerous parts of the world you mention
he said it was more frightening than a
nuclear war is that it's more
frightening than a nuclear war in this
moment the president believes
wholeheartedly that climate change is an
existential threat to the all human life
on the planet that's just science that's
fact Martha but it doesn't mean that we
turn our back on the other challenges
facing this country and our allies and
partners around the world that's just
science Martha that's just fact the sun
monster is far more threatening than a
nuclear weapon in the hands of
terrorists or any of our other enemies
that's just a fact it's just read a Blog
how do you not know that Martha love
Martha mcallum just pushing back saying
hold on I just want to be sure John
Kirby John Kirby is the NSC spokesman he
would be the White House Press Secretary
if it were not politically incorrect to
fire Karen jeanpierre who is an
absolutely awful White House Press
Secretary but who can claim a lot of
identity politics victim points because
she's a black lesbian if not for the
political incorrectness of firing her
that man would be the spokesman for the
president of the United States and that
man is defending
fully the remarks of the president of
the United States who believes that the
the temperature the sun monster the the
climate is a greater threat to us than a
nuclear weapon so this this then brings
up a
question even if you believe that
greater us involvement in this Middle
East war is warranted right now I don't
think that's a very popular position in
the US but if you are one of the people
who believe we need to start sending
sending troops in we need more troops in
we need more ships in we need to go bomb
the mulles in
Iran is this really the team that you
would trust to lead that kind of a war
you trust Joe Biden who who thinks that
Mother Earth is is a greater threat to
us than the malas that he that he says
we need to go bomb or that at least
Lindsey gram says we need to go bomb
this is the team you trust the guys who
have bungled basically every every
foreign policy decision ision in my
entire
lifetime they're the ones you trust to
lead this extremely precarious War we
were already on the brink of World War
II because of the outbreak of the first
major war in Europe since World War II
in Ukraine already on the brink then War
erupts in the Holy Land already bringing
in Lebanon now probably going to bring
in well Iran I guess was already
involved because they fund
Hamas you think that's a good idea to
have Joe Biden handling this very fresh
fragile situation the guy can't stand up
straight the guy doesn't know what his
name is the guy doesn't know what a
threat means doesn't seem like a very
good idea doesn't seem like a recipe for
Success speaking of US foreign
involvement we mentioned yesterday that
democrat congress lady Rashida
Talib has a number of flags outside of
her office none of them are the American
flag because she obviously hates America
but she has the Palestinian flag then
she has the flag of Michigan that's good
flag of the city of Detroit okay and
then she has the gay flag but she
doesn't have an American flag anywhere
to be seen and some people have taken
issue with Rashida Talib having this
Palestinian flag in particular I'm not
so hot on the rainbow flag either but
the Palestinian flag has drawn a lot of
ey and stenny Hoyer very powerful
Democrat congressman is defending Talib
should your colleague Rashida TB still
have the Palestinian flag outside of her
office I don't know what she's
Palestinian you know that doesn't mean
she's a terrorist it doesn't mean that
she condones this
rash I have I have I fly a Danish flag
uh in at my house um does it mean one
you fly a Danish flag at your house okay
do you fly one at your government office
no you don't
obviously and
furthermore I want to give stenny Hoyer
a little bit of credit here I'll even
give Rashida Talib a little bit of Grace
it is true that flying the Palestine
flag does not necessarily support for
terrorism it very often does when BLM a
couple days ago was posting the
Palestine flag next to pictures of
paragliders and saying we stand with
Palestine I think they were pretty
clearly supporting terrorism the
terrorists who parag glided in and
slaughtered
civilians but you're right it doesn't
necessarily connote support for
terrorism the more fundamental issue
here is not that Rashida talib's flag is
Palestinian the more fundamental issue
is no American politician should be
flying foreign Flags in their government
office that's very wrong I don't care
what the flag is I don't care if it's a
Palestine flag I don't care if it's an
is Israel flag for that matter I don't
care if it's a Danish flag like stenny
Hoyer is talking about I don't care if
it's a Ukraine flag I don't care if it's
an Italian flag it is very odd for us
politicians to be flying in foreign
Flags the flags of foreign governments
and Nations and would be
nations in their non- diplomatic
American government offices when did we
start tolerating that stenny H says well
she's Palestinian oh she's Palestinian I
guess she's not American then so why is
she an American
representative well no she's American oh
she's American then lose the foreign
flag lady but you got to pick one are we
what a joke of a country we have
become that we now can't even insist on
our own national flag in the case of
Rashida Talib she's not even flying the
Palestine flag next to the American flag
the only flag that's missing is the
American flag what a complete joke what
a farce it's a national Scandal and that
woman that woman should not remain in
Congress so long as her Allegiance is to
a foreign government a foreign wouldbe
Nation over our own expressed very
clearly in the symbolism outside of her
office
now I want to make myself feel better
okay what do I do when I want to make
myself feel better I sit down to a nice
juicy steak from good ranchers right now
go to goodranchers.com use code nolles
every Halloween you hear about the
dangers in the candy that your kids will
get but this year the real tricks are in
the meat aisle good ranchers wants to
take the trick out of your meat trick or
meat that's what you're going to say at
the doors this year they're throwing in
a treat for our listeners 30 bucks off
your order with promo code NOS kwas atg
goodranchers.com labg grown meat is
growing more and more popular and it's
gross foreign meat can be labeled as a
product of the United States and that
mRNA creepy laboratory developed test
nonsense is on the rise for agriculture
what is in your meat is even more in
question than ever before amid these
taunting truths the real hero arises
good ranchers the number one place to
get America's best pork beef Chicken and
Seafood delivered with good ranchers
their products are transparently sourced
All American and delicious I absolutely
love good ranchers I eat it multiple
times a week when I can that's the only
part about travel season I don't like is
I I don't get to eat my good ranchers as
nearly as much as I want to but I still
eat it a ton it's the greatest it's the
best in the business the prices cannot
possibly be beat this stuff sells itself
and you can lock in your price and it's
just it's unbelievable take the mystery
out of the medi visit goodranchers.com
use code NES kwl to get 30 bucks off
with free exper exess shipping on your
box of America's best meat and seafood
today code nolles for 30 bucks off your
box of good ranchers goodranchers.com
American Meat delivered speaking of
priorities turning to domestic affairs
California has just established a new
program the program is called ebony
alerts and the purpose of ebony alerts
is to warn people about black
children actually more than black
children who have gone missing now you
might say well that's kind of a weird
program why why would they have ebony
alerts when we already have Amber Alerts
Amber Alerts are designed to alert
people to any child who has gone missing
any child of any race you get an alert
on your phone we've all gotten them then
you look out and try to find match the
car or match the description and a lot
of children are found this way
California though has established ebony
alerts to
prioritize searches for missing black
children so if a white child and a black
child go missing in California they're
going to say forget about the white
child the black child that's the one you
got to find first the black child is
much much more important than the white
child but it's even crazier than that
because the ebony alerts don't
only warn you of of searches for missing
children it's also for young adults not
even all that young adults so for an
amber alert the the child has to be
under 17 usually there are a few
different variations of it but it's
basically for for children who are under
17 for the ebony alert it's to alert
people to missing black persons age 12
to
25 so in in California now if a a white
5-year-old goes missing and a black
25-year-old doesn't show up his parents
don't know where he
is the the black 25-year-old according
to the premise of the ebony alert will
be
prioritized over the white
5-year-old does that make a lot of sense
to you
if a white child and a black adult go
missing the black adult gets law
enforcement
priority don't forget I know it's a
little confusing Amber Alerts aren't
only for white people Amber Alerts are
for everybody but that wasn't good
enough for the libs they say no no we
need to we need to make sure that we
deprioritize white children who go
missing we need to make sure that we
give special priority to black children
really really ugly stuff but but 's
nothing surprising about
it we live at a time when white people
and to a lesser degree Asian people are
discriminated against legally in
practice they are discriminated against
there is de facto racial discrimination
against whites but there is also deure
discrimination against whites through
affirmative action which was just
recently weakened by the Supreme Court
but then all the institutions that
practice affirmative action just came
out and said oh well we'll keep doing it
we'll just hide it will hide the racial
discrimination in the personal statement
or somewhere else so that exists and
what's so ironic about it is that at the
same time we are told that there is de
facto and even deura discrimination
against black people that's the premise
of black lives matter that's the premise
of all of this leftist activism that
innocent black people are being hunted
down the LA Times published a couple
days ago black people are fleeing
America that's obviously not true 3
million black people have immigrated
into the United States over roughly the
last 20 years it's it's completely the
opposite of the truth but that's what we
come to expect when when you hear a
story from the establishment news media
or from entertainment or from Academia
you can be pretty confident that not
only is what they are telling you not
true but the opposite is true just go
check out the ebony alert laws
California going to hell in a hand
basket that's been happening for a long
time even the former Governor of
California is admitting this now the
governator anold is saying that uh the
the new democrat campaign line is that
they want to f up every city in America
here he is on Rob Lowe's podcast okay
let me ask you this and I ask people
this all the time David drer good friend
of hours yes and a a good man served for
for many many many years he used to have
the greatest what makes me a Republican
and he had I think four or five things I
think it was um in no particular strong
military low taxes less government more
personal
freedoms there might have been one a
couple but it makes sense to know strong
law enforcement strong law enforcement
and and then I'd like to know what the I
always ask Democrats what it means to be
a democrat in that way and I I think
whatever anybody would say cities what
would what would they what would they
say Ru your cities what's that ruin your
cities ruin your cities that's what the
Democrats would say we about ruining the
cities we want the up every city in
America that's what the it seems to be
the theme right now why is that I have
no idea I have no idea but that is and
that's it and he's totally right that is
the implicit campaign slogan of every
Democrat hey elect us and we're going to
completely f up your city and
everything's going to go to hell and
crime is going to go skyrocketing and
your kids are going to be indoctrinated
and abused and you're not going to trust
the security of your property or
anything else going to f up your cities
that's true and this is a fine attack
Republicans can use this but it's not
going to be the best attack I think on
Democrats and the reason for that is
Republicans don't win in cities we had
one major city in the United States
Jacksonville and we lost that right we
they have a Democrat mayor now
Republicans don't win in cities we don't
even really live in cities I have lived
in cities I've lived in New York I've
lived in LA I live in Nashville which is
a smaller City but it's
growing I do there are some I'm not
saying there are none but that's not
where we win and a lot of Republicans
who live in suburban and rural
areas actually kind of get a kick out of
it I
think at some level when the cities go
up to Hell in a hand basket because it
confirms their beliefs about Democrat
policies and about the nature of the
Cities so I don't think that's going to
be the best attack
it's a it's a fine line it's a fine
observation but I think the better
attack is going to be on something like
parental rights I think that is probably
the best line of attack that Republicans
have right now it's what got Glenn yunan
elected in Virginia it's what made Ronda
santis it's in part what made Ronda
santis very popular in Florida it works
anywhere it works in blue counties it
works in red counties works in the
country and it works in the cities yeah
they want to f up your cities those
Democrats they also want to f up your
kids we're seeing that right now we're
even seeing them admit it you remember
when drag queen Story Hour came around
am I allowed to talk about this on
social media well we'll see we'll see if
the if the bars of Doom show
up
[Music]
when everybody knows that this is wrong
everybody knows that this is wrong
that's a much better line of attack than
a lot of what're Republicans are working
with you got to protect yourself when
you want to protect yourself from
physical dangers you got to check out
bulletproof everyone right now go to
bulletproof everyone.com use code nolles
bulletproof everyone is a premier
American Body Armor manufacturer and
supplier designed and built for everyday
where their unique armor systems offer
25% more coverage than standard armor
while maintaining flexibility and all
day wearability bulletproof everyone's
ultra light armor system is so light and
thin you might just forget that you're
wearing in at your safety and discretion
is their top concern unless someone puts
their hands on you no one will have any
clue that you are protected with
bulletproof everyone you are not a
walking billboard there are no visible
logos no flashy designs they're
comfortable tailor made clothing system
goes above and beyond adding additional
security by keeping you Incognito and
under the radar work or Play Bulletproof
everyone has got the perfect armor
system to fit your everyday lifestyle
and everyday budget people are worried
about Rising tensions and Rising
violence this is a great way to protect
yourself right now our listeners can get
10% off plus a free bulletproof backpack
with the purchase of any bulletproof
clothing use code nolles at check out
bulletproof everyone.com bulletproof
everyone.com promo code nolles it's that
time of the week again this week's
episode of convicting a murderer
introduces an unlikely truth Seeker a
cadaver dog named LOF might just uncover
the hidden secrets found on Avery's
property last I checked dogs don't carry
hidden agendas or or ulterior motives
like perhaps a documentary filmmaker but
as you might expect this loyal and
honest good little boy was not featured
in the other docu series because he
discovers powerful and incriminating
evidence against Steven Avery take a
look coming up on convicting a murderer
Brendan dassi had confessed to burning
Teresa hallback's clothing but you don't
see anything about her clothing or the
Jee rivets and making a murderer he told
me to go throw it on the fire throw it
on fire the clo and it's not the only
detail that they left out other items
were found in the burn area one of them
was Teresa's tooth her ashes her bone
fragments were found in his backyard and
what do you do when she's on the fire we
threw some tires on top her and some
branches also left out are the tools
that were found around the pit there was
a shovel there was a rake you like try
to take the shovel and try to break the
BS apart you know why you don't know
about that they didn't want you to know
that because they were showing us life
in prison he's going to get and he's
only 16 and what am I supposed to do I
had told you all along keep
[Music]
your episode 8 of convicting and murder
is now available to stream exclusively
on dailywire plus new episodes of
convicting and murder released every
Thursday exclusively on dailywire plus
if you're not a member head on over to
dailywire plus.com subscribe to sign up
and get exclusive access to this
groundbreaking series and the rest of
daily wies content do not wait subscribe
today speaking of
psychos the New York Times has
just edited its description of the Hamas
terrorists so the New York
Times initially reported Hamas leaves
Trail of Terror in Israel uh as Israeli
soldiers regain control of areas near
Gaza that came under attack they're
finding evidence seen in videos and
photos and confirmed by witness accounts
of the massacre of civilians by Hamas
terrorists okay yeah basically that
makes sense then they changed it because
the New York Times appeals to a
left-wing audience and a lot of left
wiers don't like the state of Israel so
they change it to as Israeli soldiers
regain control of the areas near Gaza
blah blah blah confirmed by witness
accounts of the massacre of civilians by
Hamas gunmen it's gunmen it's not
they're not necessarily terrorists
they're
gunmen apparently they they changed
their mind over at the New York Times
that Hamas is engaged in terrorism well
how can we know one man's terrorist is
another man's Freedom Fighter you ever
hear that stupid phrase terrorism has a
meaning we argue over these words and
well well you know man what does it
really mean to be in a terrorist or in a
war the the meaning of terrorism is when
you intentionally attack civilians to
achieve political ends that's what it's
about Hamas though they did kill some
Israeli soldiers attacked civilians the
intention of the attack was to kill
civilians they didn't warn the civilians
to get out of the Rave they didn't they
didn't warn civilians and the kibuts to
go run out of there they intentionally
attacked civilians to achieve political
ends when you attack ordinary civilian
workers at the World Trade Center that
would be an act of terrorism if you were
to attack uniform
soldiers that's less clearly an act of
terrorism if you yourself are a
uniformed soldier of a legitimate
Authority attacking another uniformed
soldier of another legitimate Authority
that's not terrorism that's an act of
War there are different types of
fighting different types of killing
different types of murder what Hamas did
in Israel is not the act of a gunman
with unclear motives that's obviously an
act of terrorism there's a lot of
confusion these days on the ethics of
War our friend Anna Naro the fake
Republican who's who really truly is
just a Liber over at the view she she
doesn't even really pretend to be a
republican anymore they hired that
flunky from the Trump Administration to
be the pretended Republican Alyssa Farah
but Anna noo representing a somewhat
more center-left liberal view here is
insisting that we cannot expect the
Israeli government to have any restraint
in retaliating on Hamas on the Biden
thing you know the the the speech there
was a lot of things he said which were
very important there was also something
he didn't say which was very important
there's been many attacks on Israel
before there's been many issues in that
region before and always the re the
response from around the world has been
to Israel have restraint yesterday
nobody was telling Israel to have
restraint because you cannot call on
Israel to have restraint when 1,200 at
least of their citizens have been
slaughtered in this Savage inhumane
cruel medieval way that they have been
killed and so look we're about to see
much more Carnage it's going to get
incredibly painful the only people that
are to blame for this is Hamas Hamas is
going to be the ones cable for what's
going to happen in gasa they are holding
gasa
hostage uh as usual what anao is saying
is not true I love how she slips in
there what what these people did these
awful terrorists was
medieval lady the modern liberal age is
much bloodier and much crer and much
less coher than what happened in the
Middle Ages I promise you that this is
complete revisionist history by liberal
moderns to make ourselves feel so
enlightened and so brilliant and so
wonderful we say that oh and back in
those awful dark ages that everyone was
cruel and incoherent and and uh
basically an
animal we are behaving much more like
animals we are behaving in a much less
moral much more incoherent way than
political Society did in the Middle Ages
that's a side note
what about Anna Neo's main claim she
says that Israel cannot be expected to
show
restraint that is not true that is not
true in war at all times under all
circumstances there are certain moral
and ethical demands that are to be made
if a war is to be
just I'm not saying that Israel has
acted in an unjust way far from it I
think Israel generally conducts war in a
in a very just way
much more so than Israel's enemies for
the modern state of Israel
but there are rules there is a concept
of just War St Thomas aquinus outlined
what just war is pretty clearly just War
has to be waged by a legitimate
Authority just War has to have a just
cause and just War has to have the right
intentions and a lot of people will who
are skeptical or moral relativists today
will say well what does any of that mean
what really is a just Authority well
what really is Justice at all well what
really is the right intention okay all
right put down the bong freshman in
college you know let's talk serious if
we're going to talk about moral matters
if we're going to talk about right and
wrong then let's speak seriously about
it and not in this very silly and
sophomoric way those are the
rules Sovereign Authority Just Cause
right intentions and there are
qualifying conditions as well a just War
a war cannot be said to be just if the
belligerent intends intrinsically evil
actions that that would not count as a
just War the uh good
action uh will have or at least the
morally neutral action will have two
effects a good intended and an evil not
intended but tolerated so the evil that
accompanies War has to be merely
tolerated rather than intended and this
is a key and this is a word that's going
to crop up as we talk about what happens
now in the Middle East
proportionality the good to be achieved
has to outweigh the evils of War which
does not mean that war should be
undertaken in a purely utilitarian kind
of calculation all of those other moral
demands also have to be met and
proportionality has to be met but
proportionality is misunderstood
proportionality does not just mean that
you know if they kill 10 of your guys
you've got to only kill 10 of their guys
that's not proportionality Michael
Brendan Doty at over at National Review
uh has a a good article on this he
writes the proportion in just War theory
is not in relation to the injury you
received but to the just goals you hope
to secure that is proportionality in
just War Theory licenses the amount of
violence necessary to achieve a just
goal once again I don't want to be
misinterpreted here I think the state of
Israel generally does a very good job on
this front they warn civilians when
they're about to bomb places they tell
the civilians where to go they message
people they I think Israel is is
generally pretty good here but the
people from the peanut gallery now who
are saying things like we need to just
totally glass Gaza or we need to have
indiscriminate war or we need to just
start randomly bombing mull or other
countries they are not articulating a
moral or just view of War they are
articulating an extremely immoral view
that is extremely
dangerous not very good at all now when
you want to feel a little bit better I
would strongly recommend you check out
Tommy John right now go to Tommy
john.com it's fall which means cozy
nights in with the family and thanks to
our friends at Tommy John loungewear for
a night in is the absolute best it could
possibly be it's got The Perfect Blend
of comfort and breathability Tommy John
loungewear has a level of softness that
you have never felt before their
incredibly soft loungewear is designed
to envelop you in a world of pure luxury
I don't want to get a little TMI here
necessarily but I'm just telling you
I've I've worn many boxer shorts over
the course of my life Tommy John it's
the best the best quality it feels the
best it's just absolutely magnificent
their Lounge wear is magnificent as well
you are so much more comfortable in
Tommy John that you can do everything
better they've got dozens of comfort
Innovations breathable lightweight
moisture waking fabric four times the
stretch of competing brands that can
keep you 7° cooler than cotton every
purchase is backed by Tommy John's best
pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee get 20% off your first order
right now at Tommy john.com
that's 20% off at Tommy john.com see
site for details this was the absolute
perfect timing to shift over now to our
guest for the show Senator Rand Paul who
is one of the few people in public life
who tends to call for restraint when it
comes to questions of War he's probably
better known for that than any of his
Senate colleagues uh senator Paul has a
new book out on a totally different
topic that is also very important and
screwed up our world for three years and
a lot of people were deceived over and
he was probably the leading Senator
probably the leading us politician
calling it out and warning about it uh
that would be the coid cover up uh this
is deception the great coid cover up by
Senator Rand Paul I want to get to coid
and and what happens next with coid in
just a moment first I do want to open up
with some of these foreign policy
questions senator Paul thank you for
coming on the show good morning Michael
thanks for having me so uh Senator we
open the show today with your colleague
Lindsey Graham calling for us to bomb
Iran I think because it's a day that
ends in why Senator Graham decided to
call to bomb Iran uh is this likely is
this advisable what happens now you know
I think you do have to ask what happens
next if you were to do something what
happens if you drop a bomb on ton
currently if you look at the public of
Iran the people of Iran they're very
restless towards the uh regime Restless
towards Ki and actually many of them
pro-american I think the first bomb that
drops on ton though the nationalism of
the Iranian people those that are upset
with the Ki also become upset with the
United States as well for for an attack
Lindsey Graham said on television either
this morning or yesterday that even if
there is no direct evidence we should
still bomb them uh think that's rash
unwise and also discounts what our
constitution uh calls for our
constitution calls for debate and it
calls for the people through their
representatives to decide War I have uh
many friends whose sons and daughters
are in the military 20 22 25 years old
and if they're going to be marched off
and they're going to put their lives at
risk for the rest of us it's Our
obligation to have a a full-throated
debate on going to war anywhere for
anyone even our best of allies we have
to have a debate and has to be vote in
Congress and believe it or not people
think oh congress is so feckless we
should just let the president do this
Congress will never you know get it
right but after 911 the vote was nearly
unanimous my father who's about as
anti-war as you can get voted for the
911 authorization for Force to go in to
get those who attacked us on 911 when we
were attacked at Pearl Harbor the vote
once again nearly unanimous but we also
have to remember that after 911 many
people said Iraq did it everybody's like
Iraq did it we got to go after Iraq and
I can remember the bombs being Unleashed
on Iraq and they had so convinced our
soldiers that they were handwriting on
the bombs this is payback for 911 and it
turns out they had nothing to do with
911 doesn't mean they were a great
regime or Saddam Hussein was a Nobel
Peace Prize winner but it meant they had
nothing to do in some ways we took our
eye off of the the people who did attack
us on 9911 so I think the first thing is
first the first thing is if there are
Americans held hostage and our allies
Israelis have held hostage that's the
first priority is trying to free the
hostages um and I think the second is
trying to make sure Hamas can't do this
again and that they're incapacitated and
that will require a military
incapacitation but that'll be primarily
from Israel you know they attacked
Israel and Israel will respond and as
much as I don't want war I'm also not
one who will be mouthing off saying
Israel shouldn't do anything I'm going
to be saying Israel should do what they
need to do and only they can know best
but I think those who believe and want
to talk about the political situation of
Gaza or the West Bank they lose all
credibility who's going to listen to you
if you're killing women and children if
you're going to a a concert in the
desert and mowing down unarmed people
who wants to listen to your argument so
those people I think if anything have
unified people in support of Israel for
the most part and those who aren't at
this point you know the groups at
Harvard or the other Middle Eastern
countries around there that still blame
Israel on this um I think they lose all
credibility before we get to China and
Co I want to make one last foreign stop
up at the other potential source of the
third world war which is Ukraine you're
one of the few people in Washington who
very early on has urged caution in our
role in Ukraine uh how does the attack
in Israel uh change the war AIMS in
Ukraine the situation on the ground the
threat of a a broader global
war are we going to keep funding the war
in Ukraine is there an off-ramp is this
just going to go on forever we have no
rainy day fund we have no Surplus we
have no money to give anyone frankly we
have to borrow any money we give to
foreign
countries we essentially bought it from
China to send it elsewhere but they know
there's Rising discussion and dissension
in the Republican ranks about more and
more and more money for Ukraine so what
they're going to do and what I
understand the plan will be is this week
they will link Israel's Aid which will
be much more popular to Ukraine but then
I've also heard they're going to put in
money for Taiwan as well so it's like
just Katie bar the door we're just going
to open the floodgates of money the same
way Democrats believe in flooding the
domestic economy with borrowed money now
we're going to flood the foreign
economies with with uh printed money and
it isn't rational or or wise and what
I've asked for each time when you do it
if you think this is in our national
interest which I frankly don't think
Ukraine is but if you think it is let's
offset it let's cut spending somewhere
else there's like $25 billion doll worth
of uh semiconductor uh rund able credits
it's basically welfare to billion dollar
companies in our country you know
billion doll trillion dollar chip
manufacturers are getting taxpayer money
refundable tax credit is essentially
welfare uh there's all the new money for
the IRS there's 44 billion we could take
from the IRS there's 1.7 billion that is
going to the Taliban it's an Afghan
reconstruction fund and they say they're
only sending it for humanitarian
purposes but we believe the Taliban is
getting their hands on that money and so
in one sense we'll be saying we're
fighting Hamas and radical Islam over
here while funding it on the other side
so I'm a stickler for this even for
Israel I'm supportive of Israel I'm been
supportive of the iron D but I usually
ask that it be paid for people also have
to realize theem motions run high but
Israel's not short of money Israel is a
very wealthy country they're the most
heavily militarily stocked country in
the world probably other than the us and
we give them 3.2 billion a year on an
annual basis for the last 30 years
they've got plenty of money and plenty
of arms in addition last year in
December the Omnibus added an additional
billion for Iron Dome I don't think
anybody's saying they're out of weapons
and if they were I'm perfectly willing
to debate it but I would still ask that
we take it from someplace else where
we're wasting it the government is full
of waste but instead of that if you tell
a Democrat this they will respond and
they will say h we shouldn't have to
decide everybody should get what they
want we shouldn't have to make these
choices and it's like that's what
legislators are supposed to do make a
choice this is important this has to be
less important and we set priorities but
that's the real problem we have is we
don't do that we just give everybody
everything in Washington including China
and including that that lab and Wuhan I
mean I I suppose this is the subject of
of your book that's come out and early
on when when you called out fouchy and
you called out NIH and you raised these
questions you were called a conspiracy
theorist and the rest of us who were not
in the US Senate were called conspiracy
theorists and then it would seem that we
all turned out to be completely right
and there's been no accountability for
it at all and add on to that at least
before this this outbreak of war in the
Middle East we saw the coid restrictions
creeping up again implausibly we hadn't
seen this in something like two and a
half years and then again lion gate in
Hollywood adds The Mask restrictions uh
Morris Brown College down in Atlanta
ruter University up in Jersey all New
York City saying when you're in public
wear the masks social distance like it
was deja vu all over again
are we headed back for more
Co the amazing thing in the book is that
we prove that everything that fouchy
lied about is disprovable or proved to
be a lie in his own words now we now
have emails revealed from 2020 where
he's saying he knew they were doing gain
of function research in Wuhan and he
knew that the research was dangerous and
he knew that the virus appeared to be
manipulated he said the opposite in
public he called everyone a conspiracy
theorist he said it was a fringe Theory
we now have one of his chief lieutenants
this uh Christian Anderson who uh was
all in saying it came from the lab
saying it was gain of function research
three days later he flips and says oh no
it you're crazy if you think that but in
private emails he's saying it's not a
fringe Theory it's not a conspiracy
theory it's the most likely and logical
answer is that this virus came from the
lab but it's worse than that in the book
we reveal that there was a pause on
funding for this dangerous research and
that it was was evaded by one man by
Anthony fouchy who gave them permission
to go around the rules and then when
they set in place a Safety Committee
that said if you're doing dangerous gain
of function if you're mixing viruses
together to make them more infectious or
more lethal that you have to go before
this committee guess what the Wuhan
research all the tens of millions of
dollars that went to Wuhan none of it
ever went before the Safety Committee so
we discovered and looking at these
emails one of the emails is from January
30 ver 2020 and it's at 3: in the
morning so fouchy at 10:30 at night gets
started and it's a series of emails that
runs through 3 in the morning you get
this harried sense you get this sense of
fear building and you get this sense
that he can't sleep the last email at
three in the morning is to the guy that
runs the Safety Committee that's
supposed to review this he's knowing in
his mind or someone has told him this
research never went before the committee
in fact we have the email where his
assistant tells fouchy you know what we
don't know how this could have happened
because it never went before the Safety
Committee fouchy knows he gave an end to
run around the Safety Committee so it
wasn't just the bad decision to fund
gain of function research in a
totalitarian country it was actually the
decision then to cover it up because he
knew he would have responsibility so
they spent months and months and a year
later face to-face in committee he's
denying he's denying to my face under
oath he's saying we didn't fund any gain
of function we have never funded any
gain of function research in Wuhan so he
lied to Congress a felony and he's
gotten away with it so far so the
consequences that fouchy has faced by my
last count are a nice plushy sin ofure
at Georgetown University that that and
his retirement from NIH and his millions
of dollars from speeches and books over
the years and and other sorts of ways of
making M he also got he also got a
million dollars from a foundation a
foundation gave him a million dollars
prize for being such a great person and
he took that while being a bureaucrat
but you know what he's not even gone yet
he says he's not not working for the
government he said he retired but we
cannot get the information they will not
reveal but we do know that he still has
a limousine and 24hour surveillance uh
team that is helping him a security team
and we think he does go into his office
and we do think that he's still being
paid and our question is if he's
indicted is the federal government going
to be forced to defend him as well
because he's still an employee so
there's a lot going on here that doesn't
meet the eye but we've got nothing but
resistance we send letter after letter
to HHS into NIH is he still in the
payroll they refuse to answer we know
he's getting the limo because we've gone
around them to find the information but
he has a a limo every day pick him up to
take him to a probably a million-dollar
job at Georgetown so it's just insane in
the leftwing media has continue to cover
up for him is there any chance I I hate
to make you put on your prognosticator
crystal ball hat now but is there any
chance that he will be held to account
or is he just protected by the
government you know uh legally maybe not
you know I've referred him twice to the
Department of Justice Meritt Garland's
not exactly the most objective of
prosecutors um and really is a double
standard in our country now if you're a
republican you have to be worried about
being prosecuted but he has no fear of
being prosecuted they never will but as
far as accountability yes when this
started out in 2020 he was like a god on
Olympus and nobody touched him he was
Teflon and he was in Vogue magazine and
he was modeling and having his portrait
painted and gazing at his portrait in
his office is saying I am science and if
you criticize me you're criticizing
science all this ridiculous stuff but
you know what the pendulum has swung
quite a bit he Bamboozled most of the
scientific Community but a lot of them
got mad when they found out that the
letters saying that this was a
conspiracy theory Theory were led by
Peter daac the guy that was funneling
the money basically The Bag Man taking
the money to Wuhan is the one who
organized this and did not reveal his
conflict of interest even among
scientists of different opinions there's
there's typically agreement that if
you're being paid for by a certain
organization or Corporation If you're
receiving money you have to reveal that
in your Journal article like if this is
done by fizer you Jolly well better put
fizer's name in your paper to say it was
funded by fizer and this is a real
problem though because when I challenged
fouy on the vaccine committees I said is
anybody on the vaccine committees who's
receiving royalties from the
manufacturers of of the vaccine he
wouldn't answer the question and said he
didn't have to tell us because the law
protected him from having to reveal that
that's not really you know that
comforting that it's not happening when
they won't tell us right right uh
there's a lot more in the book uh
everyone should go get it deception the
great coid cover up by the great Senator
Rand Paul senator Paul thank you so much
for coming on thanks Michael wonderful
to see all of you the rest of the show
continues now in the mem room segmentum
do not go anywhere we will see you over
a
[Music]